we're right in the middle of the comedy
first at the moment ember gordon behind
us
on the northeast coast of scotland there
is a stretch of water that is home to
the ghost rigs
these extraordinary structures brought
here from the oil and gas fields of the
north sea
some for repairs others left to rust
for boat operator david grant they are
symbols of an industry in transition
lots changed over the years here the
rigs were built here and now they're
being taken now they've been taken apart
here yeah and i suppose they're going to
renewables now as well you know well all
wind it's all wind now isn't it
for those rigs that remain in operation
the other challenge is cleaning up
drilling and extraction is a dirty
carbon intensive business the uk's north
sea oil and gas industry is supposed to
be halving its operational carbon
emissions by 2030 and getting to net
zero by 2050 but when you get up close
to these things and you see just how
huge and complicated they are you also
get a sense of just how challenging that
decarbonization process is going to be
but whatever the difficulties port
director rory gunn is convinced fossil
fuels have staying power
even as he shows us the new wind
turbines he's helping to build i think
that if you look at the amount of
products that we use on a day-to-day
basis that are only there because of oil
and gas
and you look at the the challenges we
have on energy supply in the uk as we
see with our rising utility bills etc i
think there has to be a grown-up
discussion and a realization that
oil and gas is essential and it will be
for decades to come
that is exactly the calculation the
government has made its regulator the
oil and gas authority continues to
approve new projects in the north sea
most recently an oil and gas field
called abigail
if the uk is a climate change leader
why on earth are we even considering
approving new fields i understand the
argument i
it's a difficult and very complex
situation to to
to come to the right answer on but if we
stop new developments the uk will just
become more dependent on imports and
we'll reduce our own security of supply
options
campaigners disagree the only route to
both energy security and net zero
targets they say is the rapid end of
fossil fuels
there is absolutely no room for growing
uh the supply of oil and gas in the uk
or anywhere international energy
agency the world's leading energy think
tank declared twice last year that
there's enough oil and gas in the world
in production right now
to take us beyond the limits of the
glasgow climate agreement the paris
climate agreement we just don't need to
look for any more
the tension over a declining industry
that helped build our modern world is
playing out now in the north sea
the ghost rigs of chromity firth a
reminder of the uncertainty ahead
hannah thomas peter sky news in scotland